hey 42 here i hate to be the one to
break this to you but your face is
covered in thousands of tiny mites that
spend their days eating your skin and
their nights shagging in your paws
that might sound like the premise of a
terrible low budget horror film but
trust me it's true
they're called demo decks follicolorum
and they're about 0.3 millimeters long
with elongated bodies and four pairs of
legs stuck to their horrible little
heads
kind of like what a facehugger from
alien might look like if it really let
itself go
if you're looking for someone to blame
for this rather embarrassing infestation
of yours i suggest you have a stern word
with your mum
because it's thought the mites are
passed from mother to child during
breastfeeding
the thing is as disturbing as it may be
to discover your face is a literal
breeding ground for horrifying alien
creatures
the truth is beyond an initial desire to
give your cheek a good scratch for most
of us it's hard to get all that worked
up about face mites
that's because we humans experience the
world at a purely macroscopic level
so much so that it's easy to forget
there are even other options
but there are and the small shift in
perspective can completely change how we
perceive the world around us
and even how we perceive ourselves
[Music]
let me try and give you an example of
what i mean when you look at me now
blabbering away on your screen
you see a single object of type human
that makes a lot of sense
and yet that's only one way of looking
at things
i may be a human being but i'm also 78
different organs
five of which are vital to my continued
ability to not die those organs are
along with the rest of me made of cells
those cells are in turn made of a
complex cocktail of molecules
and those molecules are made of atoms
about seven octillion of them all told
that's a one with 27 zeros after it
so whilst it's absolutely true to say
that i'm one human being it's also
equally accurate to say that i'm a 7
octillion piece jigsaw puzzle that's
been cleverly arranged to do some pretty
neat tricks
that difference might sound entirely
arbitrary nothing more than semantics
but it turns out that when you start
looking at the world around you at an
atomic level
things start to get seriously weird
your cells regenerate on a fairly
regular basis about one percent of them
330 billion cells or so are replaced
every single day
that's fairly common knowledge but it's
rather less well known that the atoms
these cells are made of
don't regenerate
like
ever
atoms are the smallest possible unit of
any given element that still retains all
the properties of that element
so far as we know stable atoms that is
ones that aren't radioactive pretty much
last forever
it may be the case that even the stable
ones eventually break down due to
something called proton decay
but scientists haven't figured out for
certain whether or not that's actually a
thing yet and even if it is it might
take far longer to happen than the
entire future lifespan of our universe
so for all intents and purposes stable
atoms
are eternal
again that might not sound like such a
big deal
but just think about what it means for a
second
you're made of atoms and most atoms last
forever
in other words
scattered pieces of your body will still
be around when the universe finally
blinks out of existence
untold trillions of years in the future
forget the philosopher's stone or the
fountain of youth
you watching this video
are immortal
there's a flip side to that coin too by
the way
not only will the atoms that make you
still exist untold eons in the future
those very same atoms are already
mind-bogglingly ancient
despite our apparent complexity
chemically we humans are actually pretty
simple with 99 of our bodies being made
up of just four elements hydrogen oxygen
carbon and nitrogen
pretty much all the hydrogen in the
entire universe including the roughly
eight kilograms worth of hydrogen atoms
that are currently inside eu
was created during the big bang
13.7
billion years ago meanwhile your oxygen
carbon and nitrogen atoms were forged in
the fiery furnaces of ancient long dead
stars and the sprinkling of atoms from
heavier elements found inside your body
were hurled out into the cold dark
reaches of space by billion-year-old
supernovas
so
at a macro level you might be say in
your 20s or in your 30s
but
at the atomic level your body is
billions of years old
that's such a strange concept that it
almost doesn't compute
and yet in a very literal sense
it's absolutely true
most of the atoms that make your body
were created billions of years before
the formation of the sun
you my friend are an unimaginably
ancient being
you're also a surprisingly empty one
you see the incredible longevity of
atoms isn't their only freaky property
because it turns out that these building
blocks of matter are made of almost
entirely empty space
and since you're made of atoms
so are you
let me explain if i was to ask you to
sit down and draw an atom right now
you'd probably come up with something
like this
it's an example of the bohr model often
called the planetary model since it
looks a bit like a mini version of the
solar system
the atom's nucleus which is made of
protons and neutrons is like the sun
and the electrons orbit it like planets
despite being developed over a hundred
years ago by danish physicist niels bohr
the planetary model is probably the most
widely toured representation of an atom
in schools across the world even today
but in truth the model actually has some
fairly major drawbacks
for one thing the scale is miles off
although to be fair we can't really
blame niels bought for that
it's pretty much impossible to represent
an atom on a single piece of paper
for the simple reason that no page is
ever going to be big enough
atoms are incredibly tiny obviously
but the things that make them protons
neutrons and electrons
are far tinier still
if an atom was blown off to be the size
of a football stadium its nucleus would
be about the size of a peanut
the rest 99.99999
of the atom's volume
is just empty space
and
therefore
so are you
or at least that's what literally
hundreds of newspaper articles and
science magazines would have you believe
but it turns out that the whole 99.99999
empty space thing
is actually kind of a myth and it's
become so widespread for the very same
reason you've probably already forgotten
about those horny mites that live on
your face
sorry as i said at the start of this
video we humans just aren't very good at
internalizing things that don't take
place at our scale
as you probably know in our macroscopic
world the universe can be described
pretty well by the classical physics of
sir isaac newton and galileo galilei
but at the microscopic scale those laws
no longer apply down here classical
physics is weird cousin quantum physics
is king
when we look at the bohr model of an
atom we see the electrons orbiting the
nucleus like tiny planets following
distinct orbits
that's a very classical macroscopic way
of imagining what's going on inside an
atom and since classical physics has no
say at those kinds of scales
it's also completely false
in reality an electron isn't a little
particle with a neatly defined position
like a planet orbiting a star
it's a wave function that forms
something that can be best pictured as a
kind of cloud
a cloud that fills the entirety of the
atom in a sense the electron
is everywhere it wants
although thanks to the utter weirdness
that is quantum physics if we actually
attempt to measure its position at any
given moment
we'll find it somewhere incredibly
specific
but since the wave function fills the
entire atom
it's incorrect to say that we humans are
99.9999
empty space although the funny thing is
that common myth hides some truths that
are arguably just as interesting for
example you may not be mostly empty
space but by volume you are 99.9999
electron wave function
which is always nice
i guess
and that's not all
you see compared to protons and neutrons
electrons have very little mass
which is why over 99.9 percent of an
atom's mass comes from its nucleus
but as we've already seen the atomic
nucleus is unbelievably tiny compared to
the atom that houses it
and that means that over 99.9 of your
mass
comes from just 0.00
of your volume
[Music]
physics is weird isn't it
thanks for watching